let's go to the next clip which is about
Vivek ramaswamy joining Tick Tock after
the influencer turned MMA fighter Jake
Paul apparently talked him into it let's
roll that
Tick Tock is banned on government
government-issue devices because of its
ties to the Chinese government yet you
joined Tick Tock after dinner with boxer
and implementer Jake Paul
should the commander-in-chief be so
easily persuaded by an influencer so the
answer is I have a radical idea for the
Republican party we need to win
elections and part of how we win
elections is reaching the next
generation of Young Americans where they
are so when I get into office I've been
very clear kids under the age of social
under the age of 16 should not be using
addictive social media we're only going
to ever get to declaring independence
from China which I favor if we actually
win so while the Democrats are running
rampant reaching the next generation
three to one there's exactly one person
in the Republican party which talks a
big game about reaching young people and
that's me
is one of the most dangerous social
media apps that we could have and what
you've got I honestly every time I hear
you I feel a little bit Dumber for what
you say because I can't believe they
hear
situation what they're doing is these
150 million people are on Tick Tock that
means they can get your contacts they
can get your financial information they
can get your email thank you let me just
say text messages
now wanting kids to go and get on the
social media that's dangerous for all of
us you went and you were in business
with the Chinese that gave 100 Biden
five million dollars we can't trust you
we can't trust you have Tick Tock
15 seconds
15 seconds Mr ramashwali thank you I
think we would be better served as a
Republican party if we're not sitting
here hurling personal insults and
actually have a legitimate debate about
policy
I you know obviously there's several
Dimensions to this policy debate and
some of them are stupider than others I
I just find it remarkable that you know
this has been identified as a problem by
both political parties for several years
at this point and there's been a lot of
fighting over it and this nonsense that
they tried to do in the Trump
Administration where they're gonna like
get a big deal for Oracle to do the
server provision for tick tock which
didn't seem to address any of the
problems but would make a whole bunch of
money for Oracle but basically you know
the the criticism here that I think is
the most valid is that you know free
speech and free markets not require you
to allow an authoritarian foreign
government to own and control a media
entity in the United States and in fact
we've already forced the Chinese to
discourage one social platform which was
Grindr uh which was acquired by a
chinese-controlled company a few years
ago and that was reviewed by the the
sypheus committee in the treasury
Department and found that that was
National Security risk and they were
forced to sell the app back to a US
owner
um and that you know that that didn't
interfere with people's ability to
access grinder but it did ensure that
you know that we were protecting this
you know this platform that contained a
lot of information from Americans from
being controlled by a by a hostel
foreign entity and I think you know I
think it is a real concern that you know
the tick tock algorithm which is a Black
Box gives the Chinese government which
is unelected a lot of ability to to
influence the way in which information
is received by Americans I don't think
we would have allowed the Soviets to do
that during the Cold War and so it
seemed it feels to me like there's a
there's a relatively narrow policy area
here where the you know there's there's
some talk of whether you could use the
existing law that was used for grinder
whether you could use that on Tick Tock
because of some us-based entities that
they've already acquired saying that you
know Tick Tock is a formerly U.S company
that was acquired but even if it wasn't
you could have a new law and you could
have a solution where you don't take
Tick Tock away from anyone but you make
sure that it is not controlled by the
Chinese government which it seems to me
like that there shouldn't even be a
Libertarian objection to because we're
not here to protect the the association
rights of the Communist Chinese
government
is like what in your view I mean the
stuff that you have read what do you
think the harm caused by Tick Tock and
tick tock's access to Americans data is
like do you mind just like going into a
little bit of detail there because I so
frequently get frustrated by this
conversation in this debate because it's
like this is bad but people infrequently
expand on what specifically is bad about
it so my main concern is about the
algorithm and the and the content that
people are viewing more than it is about
the user data I you know I think that
you know we first of all we don't know
the extent to which that they're making
algorithmic choices that are promoting
messages that are favorable to the
Chinese government or suppressing
messages that they don't like but the
other thing is that you know if you when
they control this platform that like
half of Americans are using they can
they can do that and flip a switch in
the future and it takes years to do to
rest control of it away from them so I
think it's you know it's worth doing
even if we haven't identified something
that they are doing yet because
especially if you know if we got into a
situation if there was a war over Taiwan
for example where the tensions were even
higher between the U.S and China I don't
think we'd want them having that sort of
power as for user data I'm not that
concerned about them having you know
large volumes of data on lots of
Ordinary People which is probably a very
little value to the Chinese and there
are supposed to be certain privacy
protections that are that are created by
the apple and the Google App Stores I
don't have a good technological sense of
how foolproof that stuff is
um but you know you you certainly you
could have specific targets of Chinese
surveillance where it might be useful to
have access into some relatively small
number of people's phones and I think
that could be a concern but my my main
concern is about Tick Tock as a media
company rather than to talk as a company
that has user data
machine that can just easily be right
you know dispensing you know bad
information to people in the event of
like a Taiwan Invasion okay that makes
sense yeah let me say this it's a it's a
legitimate concern for sure
um it is important to be real precise
and like dig down into the details of
what it is the government would be
banning I mean the company that you know
there's a parent company that owns Tick
Tock that is based in China and also
runs a Chinese version of tick tock
which is much different there's a
separate company based in the US that
supposedly runs the U.S version and they
say there's a firewall it's unclear how
strong that firewall is I would want any
sort of ban on you know manipulation of
the public through this kind of
propaganda you're talking about to be
pretty well proven out uh and something
that we the public would be able to see
instead of what we tend to get which was
the law that was proposed to ban Tick
Tock in the first place I encourage
people to go watch this the stream we
did on this which was a sprawling law
that would like you know was throwing in
trying to regulate crypto and Bitcoin
and like all uh telecommunications
infrastructure so that's kind of these
things just kind of get all jammed
together into this big power grab and
that's what I as a Libertarian get
really nervous about uh anytime we start
regulating uh social media even if it's
you know potentially a hostile social
media so yeah if you can prove that
there's some sort of
um you know propagandizing uh
intentional propagandizing happening
from a hostile foreign government that's
one thing but to Liz's point it it can't
be it can't be vague and it has to be
extremely targeted yeah I wouldn't want
the government regulating the algorithm
I mean first I don't really trust the
government to do that and then also like
even if the government did impose a
regulation I don't know how we would
ensure that that Tick Tock under Chinese
control was following the regulation
um what I want is is Ultimate Amer
American control and ownership over the
company
um and you know the I the our
Constitution and our culture of free
speech requires that you know that
people be able to do things like you
know decide what kind of information
they want to disseminate on their media
platform I don't really I don't want the
to take that out of the private sphere I
actually want to move it into the
private sphere so that it's not the
Chinese government so that it's some
private American entity doing that
I think it's also worth lingering on the
idea that the federal government is
going to regulate whether teenagers have
access to social media
um that seems like one of the crazier
ideas that is just routinely floated out
there on that stage I mean I think you
know Vivek uh he has it in for the young
people in general uh between that and
his uh proposal to you know make
everyone serve in some sort of civil
service in order to be able to vote
until their age uh you know a higher I
think age 21 or 25. it was 25.
25 okay yeah so you know he's going on
uh Tick-Tock uh with uh Jake Paul but I
don't think he's courting the the youth
vote in fact he wants to outlot hey
thanks for watching that conversation
with Josh Barrow about the recent GOP
debate you can watch the full
conversation right here or another clip
over here